are you ready to apply for your first
dream job
the first step to get there is to have a
well-crafted resume
resumes are the first point of contact
with recruiters
only if your resume is impressive will
you make it to the interviews
resumes speak volumes about you to the
hiring panel
today we bring you this informative
video on resume tips for freshers
if you are stepping into your work life
for the first time
not to worry we have you covered with
these top tips to polish your resume
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from simplylearn
a resume is a document that highlights
your career goals education
skills achievements and interest areas
hence
it is of utmost importance that you
package your resume well to get
shortlisted by hr's
you barely have six to seven seconds to
create a positive impression with your
resume
here are the top 10 tips that will help
you craft an impressive fresher resume
one first and foremost you need to pick
the right type of resume before filling
in your details
since you are a fresher you should go
with a format that emphasizes more on
your skills
hence as a fresher you can go with a
functional resume
two our next tip to you is to have a
blueprint of your resume
it is wise to pre-plan and organize the
resume content
this way you will better understand what
needs to be in the resume
and what can be omitted three before you
fill in your resume
be sure to add your contact information
this includes your name
your address your email id and your
phone number
you could also add your linkedin profile
link for better credibility
now with many interviews happening
online you can also mention your skype
id
make sure that every detail you give
looks professional
four the next point to keep in mind is
to have an impressive
short and powerful headline resume
headlines give an overview of your
background to the recruiters
hence craft a good 2-3 liner summary
about your career goals and
qualifications
you could also add some relevant
keywords from the job description to
capture the recruiter's attention
which will help you stand out from the
rest of the candidates
so here's a small task for y'all can you
craft a very short
one or two liner impressive sample
headline that will go on your resume
and drop it in the comments section
below let's have a look at how creative
all of us can get
and this will also help us get ideas
from one another
five since you are a fresher the next
step is to highlight your education
have a table and list down your
educational details including the time
in reverse chronological order
up to your 10th standard you would also
need to mention your cgpa
or your percentage in a separate column
make sure to align
all these details in your table below
this you can also have a section for
your additional education details
and mention the certifications you
possess in any presented papers
six now it is time to highlight your
skills
choose a set of technical skills and
soft skills that you possess
and at the same time those that are
relevant to the job role
you are applying for again you can
sprinkle a few skills that are mentioned
in the job description
while listing your skills it is wise to
use a two column format that names the
skill
and your level of experience with the
skill
seven since you are a fresher you might
have little to no work experience
hence add your internships and project
details instead
mention the duration for the same and
list out a few points as to what you did
make sure to keep it easy to read and
structure the content in the form of
bullet points
eight our next tip for you is to add a
section that throws light into your
co-curricular activities
here you can briefly list down points
about hackathons college fest
sports and so on this displays your
passion
and shows that you're an all-rounder if
you have hosted events or activities
feel free to mention those as it will
display your leadership skills
here you could also mention your hobbies
and interests
you can also add a miscellaneous section
mentioning the languages you know
and any other accomplishments you are
proud of nine
another rule to keep in mind while
crafting your resume is
to be honest ensure you don't add false
information
as it will leave a bad mark on your
profile forever
as a refresher it is advised that you
keep your resume within two pages
and not more than that a simple short
and crisp resume
will do the job on that note here's a
sample resume structure
if you want a detailed resume that can
help you grab your dream job
please share your email in the comment
section below and we will send it over
to you
10 and our last tip to you is to
proofread your resume
nothing can be worse than having typos
or grammatical errors in your resume
check for spelling mistakes and sentence
structure having such errors will leave
a bad impression on the recruiter
and you might seem careless in addition
to this
make sure your resume is well formatted
and you use the same font type
throughout your resume
after carrying out all these checks
remember to share only the pdf version
of your resume with the recruiters
so those were our top 10 resume tips for
freshers
being an excellent candidate with the
perfect set of skills
won't help if you cannot put that across
through your resume
therefore it is imperative you craft
your resume well and follow our tips to
help you land
your dream job that brings us to the end
of this video
i hope these resume tips are helpful to
all you freshers out there
and we wish you all the very best thank
you for watching the video
and stay tuned for more from simplylearn
[Music]